is Trump pushing the culture wars or our
Democrats plus updates on the Jeffrey
Epstein case and Chris Cuomo of CNN
confronts a heckler I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show Wow wild and
variegated news cycle today we're gonna
get through all of it in just an hour I
mean we're really gonna pump through
this stuff in far less than an hour
actually we begin today with the most
important story of the day and that of
course is CNN's Chris Cuomo gets into an
altercation with a heckler so as
somebody who has had hecklers in public
before then you say that how you handle
hecklers is kind of important part of
your job as a public figure now I have
been rarely confronted by people while I
am with my family but there are jerks
out there who will do this there are
people who will come out come up to you
and say something nasty when you are
with your family and generally the best
tactic is to basically push them off and
let them go I don't mean physically push
them off just kind of like back off so
you're gonna say man and then just take
off and it's not a sign of weakness
that's a sign of being smart because
getting into an altercation likely ends
with cell phone video of the altercation
at the least and a lawsuit at the most
it's never a very good idea I mean this
happened to me like a couple of weeks
ago we were out in public somewhere and
some woman came up to me while I was
with my kids and her five and three and
my wife was somewhere else think she's
going the restroom or something and I'm
holding my five-year-old in one hand my
three-year-old in the other hand and
some woman comes up to me to explain
that I'm a white supremacist as like
well you know we'll have to agree to
disagree
have a nice day and off you went well
that is not exactly how things went with
Chris Cuomo so a bunch of things can be
true one hecklers are jerks people who
come up to you in public I don't care
what your politics they come up to you
in public they come to Ted Cruz and they
come up to me I come to Sarah Huckabee
Sanders it come up to Chris Cuomo if you
go up to Chris Cuomo when you start
calling him names in public when he's
with his family
you're a jerk okay there's one thing to
make him make fun of him on a show like
this because that's the nature of the
game that's the nature of political
entertainment that's the nature of the
dialogue but I promise you that if I
were in a room with Chris Cuomo I
wouldn't be insulting him and nor would
he be insulting me that's not the way
this works now somebody went up to Chris
Cuomo in a public place and started
calling him by a name that we on the
right frequently used for Chris Cuomo
Fredo and the reason people call him
Fredo is not because he's Italian
the reason that people call him Fredo is
because that's a reference to the dumb
brother from The Godfather
obviously the implication being that his
brother is the smarter brother I've been
saying for a long time that there's an
open competition between Chris Cuomo and
his brother Andrew as to which is the
Dumber Cuomo brother usually Chris tends
to take the cake
sometimes Andrew surpasses him although
that's a rare occasion in any case Chris
Cuomo is out in public and some young
dude walks up to him kids a jerk and
calls him Fredo and again I understand
Chris Cuomo getting angry I really do
I've been there myself
I understand Chris Cuomo getting ticked
off and telling the guy off I get that
but where Chris Cuomo goes with the term
Fredo is a very weird place and where
the media then go with this story is an
even weirder place so here is the
altercation if you can hear the audio
rado the Godfather it was a weak brother
and they use it as an Italian aspersion
maybe your time
[Music]
okay so you do want to ramp down the
aggression just a little bit this is not
the smart way to handle all of this now
Sean Hannity came out and praised to
push Guam one's head Cuomo did nothing
wrong here made a couple things wrong
here number one let's be clear if
there's were somebody on the right
shouting at a protester and threatening
to throw them down the effing stairs it
would be another in the line of data
points proposed by the media that the
right is too violent there's just no
question I mean if this had been a video
of me and public threatening to throw
some guy down the stairs it would be
Shapiro unhinge Shapiro loses it the
same thing is true of any fox news host
or any talk radio host that's just the
way the media operate when it's Chris
Cuomo it's brave man stands up to young
heckler right that's number one number
two what is he talking about when he
says that Fredo isn't is like the n-word
for Italians no the n-word is mostly
like the n-word mostly Fredo is not like
the n-word for Italians because that's
crazy I was so curious about this like
maybe I had missed it that I actually
googled Fredo and ethnic slur yesterday
there is not a single relevant hit on
Google not one it has never been an
ethnic slur it has always been something
you say about a dummy if you think
somebody's a dummy then you say that
they are Fredo right if they're the
weaker younger brother if they're right
everyone flashes to the scene from The
Godfather of John Cazale saying I'm not
dumb I'm spot right somebody who really
has an outsized opinion of their own
intelligence and it's insistent that
they can handle things but they're
absolutely incompetent cannot handle
things right that is what the term Fredo
has come to mean and to be fair I really
don't think that when it pertains to CNN
Chris Cuomo probably is in Fredo
probably Jim Acosta Fredo probably Chris
Cuomo is more like Sonny right he's
gonna beat somebody to death with the
top of a trash can or something and that
makes Jake Tapper by default Michael
probably will get some more everything
is absurd guys we live in The Godfather
Jeffrey Epstein is Frank pant Angela
his veins in the bath and then you've
got Chris Cuomo who is very upset that
somebody called him Fredo the whole
thing is rude
I don't know what blackhole we entered
to end up in this parallel universe but
it was the most fun of the black hole's
probably this is wild ok we'll get to
that and say first let's talk about the
fact that you probably don't get enough
sleep I don't get enough sleep and very
often I have trouble falling asleep or
if I wake up in the middle of the night
I've trouble falling back to sleep and
this is why I use the column app it's
why we partner with comas the number one
app for sleep with calm you'll discover
a whole library of programs designed to
help you get to sleep your brain and
body need including soundscapes and over
a hundred sleep stories narrated by
soothing voices like Jerome Flynn from
Game of Thrones if you want to seize the
day you first need to sleep the night so
trichome if you don't sleep you're not
gonna be as mentally fresh you're not
gonna be as physically capable you might
end up screaming at some heckler and
threatening the throne down the stairs
or something now you need your sleep you
need to relax and this is why you need
calm right now my listeners get 25% off
a comb premium subscription at calm calm
slash patent that CA LM calm slash been
forty million people have downloaded
call them find out why at comb calm
slash man it also works with kids by the
way if your kids are having trouble
falling asleep you put on some of the
sleep stories for kids
it'll be out like a light check out calm
calm so I spend get twenty five percent
off that calm premium subscription at
calm calm slash man go check him out
okay so if you couldn't actually hear
the audio this guy walks up to Cuomo he
calls him Fredo and Cuomo says no
punk-ass from the right call me
Fredo my name is Chris Cuomo I'm an
anchor on CNN and frado's from the
Godfather he was that week brother
they're using it as an Italian aspersion
it's like the n-word for us and then he
threatens to throw the guy down the
stairs like like a bleeping punk and so
as I say you know when it comes to
people having outsized reactions to
people heckling them in public I have a
lot of sympathy when it comes to Fredo
is like the n-word not so much now
here's the hilarious part CNN not only
defended Cuomo's behavior which is which
is fine they actually came out and
defended the notion that Fredo is a slur
so all it does to turn a word into a
slur is have an anchor at CNN call it a
long-standing ethnic slur
Fredo is not an ethnic slur you know how
I know because I'm saying it right now
Fredo not Netflix ler now we say the N
word we say the N word when we say the F
word the slur that's been used for gay
people we say the F word on this program
if I were to say these slur use for Jews
you'd be the K word right we all know
the ethnic slurs but Fredo is not an
ethnic slur and I can tell cuz I'm using
it like Fredo you see how I did that
right there noth-nothing mix her CNN
defends its anchor with this statement
quote Chris Cuomo defended himself when
he was verbally attacked with the use of
an ethnic slur
in an orchestrated setup we completely
support him it's not an ethnic slur it
isn't you know how I know that it's not
nothing so I have a few ways I know it's
not nothing accelerant way number one I
know it's not nothing next look like you
would assume that if it were a terrible
terrible ethnic slur then if somebody
used it like in front of Chris Cuomo
probably but not about Chris Cuomo he
would stop them right if somebody used
the n-word in front of you you would
stop them he said it's not appropriate
stop using that sort of language around
me right what if somebody used it in
front of you on national TV then you
certainly would stop it you take guys we
can't do this right we can't we can't
use that kind of language on TV that's
that's derogatory and gross okay here's
an owner of our like five months ago
likening one of trumps sons to Fredo
zhuzh maybe have fences to protect the
animals from people like Donald Trump
jr. who like to shoot them this is an
entitled rich spoiled little brat who's
only called to fame as being his daddy's
son who hasn't built anything of his own
who hasn't done anything of his own who
is somehow trying to hang on to the fame
of his father in order to have some
level of relevancy Steve was right he
didn't even make the cut but that his
brother-in-law and sister did to be part
of the Oval Office and the White House
staff daddy kept Fredo back home so who
cares what Donald Trump jr. says look at
look at Chris Cuomo jump in right there
and say Anna you really can't use the
kind of language on my show did you hear
him say it I didn't either cuz you
didn't say it cuz it's ridiculous
because who cares it's ridiculous there
a bevy of articles online calling the
Trump family members Fredo
again it is not nothing
everyone knows it's not an ethnic slur
apparently except for except for Chris
Cuomo and even then it's only an ethnic
slur when applied to Chris Cuomo if you
were such an ethnic slur then I don't
think you get Chris Matthews just a few
months ago calling Don jr. Fredo I got
mine in here
here I'll rub up look like I slept
underneath at Sutton embankment
literally a window under the freeway and
I roll on in here Oh looking weird come
out with a show got on that seat rel
around and start calling people Fredo
using ethnic slurs like that one time I
went to an Italian restaurant and I
ordered some fettuccine fettuccine
alfredo huh go like inviting that the
son Fredo like son of the President to a
meeting to give him dirt on the his
father's opponent in a way that a child
would accept that anyone else is a
weight of it I'm not going to meeting
with the Russians yeah he's a junior
he's like Fredo it's not an ethnic slur
it's just how we use language out here
and there's some vicious brutal racist
like everyone else on the right Chris
Matthews using the word Fredo
no one cares because it's not ethnic
slur cuz this is all ridiculous okay
that parts the parts again I am NOT on
Chris Cuomo's case for getting up in
somebody's face who is bothering him in
public it's not something that I would
do I don't think it's good practice but
I do understand the reaction because
again when people confronts other people
in public and act like jerks and people
lose it I kind of get it I kind of get
it however I would not expect the left
to extend the same courtesy to anybody
on the right I remember when Tucker
Carlson was confronted at a restaurant
in front of his kid and people have left
lost it how could Tucker Carlson be such
an unhinged maniac going crazy in a
restaurant so I wouldn't expect the same
courtesy from those on the left mainly
because people on the Left very often
don't see people on the right as human
beings like I think Chris Cuomo is wrong
about a lot of things I don't think he's
very good at his job but he's a human
being and so I understand him having a
human reaction for a lot of folks on the
left people on the right are simply not
human and so if Tucker Carlson gets
confronted at a restaurant and then gets
in somebody's face that's because Tucker
Carlson is a monster because it doesn't
matter what the beginning of the
sentence is the end is always Tucker
Carlson as a monster if you are somebody
on the left nonetheless I leave the
equation of Fredo with the
is quite astonishing and frankly I don't
know how Chris Cuomo is able to get away
with comparing everything he doesn't
like to the N word if somebody on the
right to this you would assume that this
amounted to a tremendous racial
insensitivity if you just kept saying
that X Y or Z was the equivalent of the
n-word on the right they would say well
you don't understand the n-word you
don't understand the context you don't
understand
it's a place in American life there's no
real equivalent to the n-word all of
that would be true all of that would be
true and if somebody on the right did
this if somebody um if somebody came up
to me and and used the the the very oft
used sort of alright rhetoric against
somebody come up to me and like ah
you're short you're 5'4 and I was like
you know that's the equivalent of the
n-word people like well that's kind of
insensitive to black folks isn't it to
black people that mean like that's not
the n-word that's just somebody calling
you short five nine for the record in
any case Chris Cuomo that's not the
first time that he has equated something
with the n-word and he's got to stop
doing it guys it's not good policy and
CNN backed him on it right CNN was like
yes Fredo is an ethnic slur
not an ethnic slur here is just a few
months ago Chris Cuomo declaring that if
you use the term fake news fake news is
like the n-word for members of the media
which makes perfect sense because
members of the media have been ganged up
on lynched hanged for centuries in
America enslaved treated like
second-class citizens subjected to Jim
Crow wait none of that has happened to
journalists so this is a bunch of crap
here's Chris Cuomo saying a dumb thing
about the n-word I see being called fake
news as the equivalent of the n-word for
journalists the equivalent of calling an
Italian on any of the ugly words that
people have for that ethnicity that's
what fake news is to a journalist it is
an ugly insult and you better be right
if you're going to charge a journalist
with lying on purpose it's just like the
n-word it's just like the n-word it's
how it could for Chris Cuomo everything
apparently that offends him is like the
n-word by the way I just want to put it
out there if Fredo is an ethnic slur for
Italians a few others we should be
careful of Frodo is apparently an ethnic
slur for hobbits and Greedo is actually
an ethnic slur for Rodian bounty hunters
so we should be very careful about the
kind of verbiage that we use we don't
want to trigger people
we don't want them to get too upset
enter Donald Trump through the wall like
the kool-aid man is there a controversy
the bat-signal is up in the night sky
the big t for Donald Trump somewhere
someone has said something foolish and
Donald Trump must weigh in said Donald
Trump descends like the Caped Crusader
he is into the middle of what is an
irrelevant stupid fight any-any jetpacks
in there like The Rocketeer he says if
that Chris was afraid of Elsa the truth
hurts totally last at low rating CNN
yeah come on guys
that's some funny bleep come on I mean
like I understand not Lincoln right not
what we get it we get it okay we get all
the critiques I get Bill Kristol ripping
on him demeaning the office of the
presidency I get all I understand okay
I'm on the same page guys but come on
this is funny if you can't appreciate
the fact that a CNN anchor who hosts
Trump a white supremacist on a fairly
regular basis is likening Fredo
the young stupid brother from The
Godfather to the n-word and the Donald
Trump is then jumping in to be like
that's right fraida get it Fredo the
truth hurts
totally lasted low ratings it's like
she's a bot programmed to watch a
thousand hours of Trump and then this is
what the tweets come up with at this
point I don't even know that Trump was
tweeting for himself there's a robot
Trump tweeting for Trump just taking old
phrases of trumps and then stringing
them together in tweets all the tweets
are three word phrases I just love my
favorite is the tag at the end low
ratings at CNN
what does that have to do with anything
but it's the best and also the worst and
the best also it's a I thought Chris was
Fredo oh yeah I love that movie that
movie's great didn't really understand
the plan - Godfather - and Godfather
three why would he ditch Bridget Fonda
for Sofia Coppola of Sofia Coppola makes
no sense but Chris Fredo
I'm the Mack mr. president you're
required to the Situation Room sir well
the good news is this means that the
media will now have to declare that
Fredo is in fact an ethnic slur for
Italian stood out from said it right so
now we're just gonna rewrite the whole
English language because everything from
says is an ethnic slur oh my god it's so
absurd everything is absurd how did we
enter this reality how do we get back to
the regular reality where Mitt Romney is
president since 2012 I don't we how do
we get back there I don't know but I
also know it won't be nearly as
entertaining we'll get to more of this
if there's more to get to if I can
handle if I can handle my bleep here
we'll get back to that in just one
second first we need to talk about
something very serious and talk about
your underwear of course the fact is the
underwear that you are wearing right now
they've fallen apart because you wore
them 35 times and you stuff them in the
wash and now they're falling apart
because they weren't durable and they
weren't nice and they weren't decent
instead you just went you got like a $10
yeah a $10 pack for 12 pairs of
underwear now they're all falling apart
on you the elastics falling apart it's
really uncomfortable it's riding up on
you well this is why you need Tommy
John's Tommy John doesn't just claim to
be the most comfortable underwear on the
market they actually have the stats to
back it up like this number over seven
million which is the number of pairs of
Tommy John underwear
they've sold with 96% of their customers
rating them with four stars or greater
with Tommy John's revolutionary
underwear the legs never ride up and the
waist bands never roll down Tommy John
is more than just underwear they've got
750 products online such as super soft
lounge who are polo shirts and apparel
Tommy John is so sure you're gonna love
the fit and feel that it's all backed by
their best pair you'll ever wear or it's
free guarantee how do I know that Tommy
Shaun underwear are spectacular because
they grace my punk ass took us right now
that means if you don't love your first
pair you will get a full refund Tommy
John no adjustment needed hurry over to
Tommy John calm right now Tommy John's a
calm slash Ben and get 20% off your
first order that's Tommy John calm slash
Ben for 20% off Tommy John calm slash
Ben all right so the the fact that the
President of the United States is
sounding off on I thought well my
westphalia but is the best it's the fact
that he's doing that this means that the
media naturally are going to have a 48
hour news cycle about how Trump is so
unpresidential
yeah we
get it we all know whatever man I mean
whatever man is I think the reaction of
most Americans at this point did we
think that we were actually getting
George Washington when you elected the
guy from The Apprentice who is mostly
famous for saying that he fired people
like what did you think that you were
getting when you elected the guy who was
revealed on tape three weeks before the
election talking about how often you
like to grab women by the genitals like
we all get it right so and and the guy
who tweet he's a stand-up comedian right
man who tweets like this now to get
serious for just a brief moment I will
note that there is something that is
going on in our country that actually is
dangerous but it's not dangerous in the
sense that like Trump is responsible for
it or Trump is is responsible for all of
these stupidities of people going out
and confronting people in public in fact
I think that the left is is actually
more responsible than the right for
stuff like this because the left cheers
it on I mean within the last week the
left was cheering on a sitting Congress
person daxing Trump donors within the
last week the left is calling for open
boycotts of companies that have
stockholders who donated to President
Trump there were full editorials in the
Washington Post talking about why Sarah
Huckabee CNR should be hounded out of a
restaurant we've seen videos of Candice
owns and Charlie cook from TP USA being
harassed outside a restaurant and that
was not a national story so that this
sort of stuff has been going on for
quite a while from the left public
heckling and not not just public
heckling people attempting to do
violence people mobbing folks on the
right I mean this obviously has happened
to me several times at different
universities so the sort of stuff has
been happening for quite a while but we
are seeing it is ugly is the bleed over
from the online sphere into the real
world and this is a lack of social
institutions on a broader level right on
online was supposed to be more fun now
online was the place that you went I
remember at the beginnings of the
internet the very or let me take you in
the Wayback Machine in small children
and I'll take you back to the origins of
the Internet when you sat next to your
AOL dial-up and you listened to the
horrible sounds the horrible grating
sounds that connected you online and
then if you're like 12 or 13
you found chat rooms with people who
went to school and who are your age and
you would chat about movies or you'd
chat about sports and online was just
kind of like a thing that you did for
maybe half an hour a day and then you
went outside you played with your
friends and now online has taken over
everybody's life and so predictably
speaking people are taking the online
world in which they are now spending
more time than they are the real world
and they are taking the effects of the
online world in there they are now
applying it to the real world
in the most extreme cases you're seeing
this in the most evil ways with places
like HN where people create an
alternative reality for themselves and
then they go out into real reality and
carry out their sick fantasies in public
well you see this on a smaller scale
when you go to a college campus and
people are our mobs or when you're out
in public and people harass you because
they and then tape it because they want
to show all their friends that there are
virtuous folks who are standing up to
the modern-day evil that is the right
wing or the modern-day evil that is
Chris Cuomo well yeah I think we're not
focusing enough on the kid here whose
jerk focusing in on Cuomo because Cuomo
is in fact adults but the the person who
went up to Cuomo and called him Fredo in
public is a jerk and I think that that
is becoming more common on both right
and left and a lot of that has to do
with lack of militating social
institutions it has to do with the fact
that we are engaged too much online to
begin our validation from how many
clicks and likes we get on places like
Twitter and Facebook and what that means
is also that stuff that people said
10-15 years ago ingest because it was
just a thing you did for fun online now
people are going back in there applying
the new Internet ethics which is that
the real world is the online world and
they are applying it to fifteen-year-old
statements which is why you see people
digging up old statements by comedians
on Twitter and then treating it as
though they said it in public in real
life in front of a crowd of a thousand
people we treat online like the real
world and we treat the real world like
online now it used to be that there was
much more of a division between the two
and this is going to lead to more and
more dangerous confrontations now this
this confrontation with Cuomo wasn't
dangerous this was a guy who was just
being a jerk and Cuomo backed him off
and Cuomo was really aggressive with him
and again not something I would done not
something I think is particularly smart
and if somebody on the right had done it
the media would be up in arms plus Chris
Cuomo's adult if he thinks that Fredo is
a slur on the order of the n-word or a
slur at all frankly but as far as the
the behavior of people in public it is
getting worse it is getting uglier
because people want to take the spoils
of what they do in real in real life and
then they want to go back to the video
game that is the online world and brag
to all their friends that they have
racked up virtue coins it's like out
there in the real world remember
the old Mario Brothers game where Mario
is running through the landscape picking
up coins but then rain every time he
picks up a coin he moves closer to
another life that is what we do in the
real world now we rack up points in the
real world by taking tape of stuff that
happens and then putting it online for
the likes and the clicks and the fake
social acceptance that comes along with
it and that I do think is actually kind
of dangerous again in one second I'm
gonna get to some real news of the day
beyond the fact that the President of
the United States tweeted out that Chris
Cuomo is Fredo which is just I got to
admit hilarious we'll get to more of
that in just one second first let's talk
about how you make your neighborhood
safer as it feels like safety in major
cities around the United States is
degrading it is important to protect
your home and this is true whether
you're afraid of somebody who's gonna
break into your home's do you violence
or if like I am or if you are just
concerned that somebody is breaking into
your house they're gonna ring the
doorbell see if you're home and then
break in and take all your stuff this is
why you need a ring rings mission is to
make neighborhoods safer and they are
doing just that protecting millions of
people everywhere they've got their
smart video doorbell they've got cameras
that make sure that your property has a
ring of security around it I don't just
have a ring most of my friends have
rings at this point ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you'll get an
alert and be able to see hear and speak
to them all from your phone this
definitely makes me feel safer while I'm
out on the road it means that I can tell
who is pulling up to my house
even if I happen not to be at home at
the time I love the ring devices I think
you will too as a subscriber you have a
special offer on a ring welcome kit
available right now at ring.com slash
pen that's ring.com slash pen the kit
includes a video doorbell and a chime
Pro which is just what you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home today go to ring.com slash Ben
that's ring.com slash Ben go check them
out right now ok so on to the twenty20
race where the Democratic Party has
basically settled in on its narrative
its narrative is that Donald Trump is
fighting terrible terrible culture wars
and that the culture wars are in fact
Donald Trump's fault the culture wars
did not predate Trump the culture wars
came along with Trump the world began
spinning when Donald Trump and now when
he came down that escalator that is when
the universe was formed it was the Big
Bang of politics Trump was not a symptom
of a broken political system Trump was
not a symptom of culture civil wars that
we've been
fighting in this country for a decade
mainly during the Obama administration
thanks to polarization along economic
and racial lines now Donald Trump was
the initiator of all of this and this is
the narrative Democrats are going to run
with because they have to run with that
narrative remember if they acknowledge
the truth which is that a lot of this
polarization started really under george
w bush and then exacerbated radically
under barack obama and now has
exacerbated again under donald trump if
they were to acknowledge that then it
would make them have to abandon their
main point in this election cycle which
is the return to normalcy point Joe
Biden is running as a return to normalcy
candidate he's running as the guy who's
gonna restore some sense of calm and
order to the United States but if people
correctly recollect back just four years
ago when Barack Obama was in power and
Ferguson was rioting and burning and
Baltimore was rioting and burning and we
were seeing police officers gunned down
in the streets of Dallas if we all
recollect back then then the return to
normalcy campaign doesn't have quite the
same feel does it because things weren't
normal things were really messed up and
then rest up in different ways now but
they were messed up before Trump ever
got on the scene so this means the
Democrats and the media have to put out
there the line that the culture wars we
are currently experiencing are solely
due to the peckish temperament and
bizarre character of President Trump as
opposed to underlying issues that the
that the country has been facing for
quite a while here and that burst out
really into the open and extraordinarily
ugly ways during the Obama
administration and now continuing on
into the Trump administration now the
reason Democrats have to run on the
culture war kind of stuff is because if
they run on policy they're gonna get
skunked most people are not interested
in Kamala Harris nationalizing their
health care in Kamala Harris went to an
old-age home in Iowa one of the bizarre
things about how American campaigns are
run is that you end up with tape of
Kamala Harris at an old-age home in Iowa
a retirement home in Iowa first of all
all those people were like 17 when she
incarcerated them and now they're like
85 but she went there and she actually
played bingo with the members of the
old-age home and then a woman asked her
so you're gonna take away my health care
aren't you and come with Harris is like
no no she's like yeah you are aren't you
come I was like no kind of and ladies
don't do it pretty amazing
[Music]
University okay okay I don't intend to
well I want to make sure your help here
is the way you like so I'll promise you
that okay lies lies don't lie to the old
lady kamila it's not nice to lie to old
people
hey it's not nice to to jail my man it's
also not nice to lie to them so she gets
wrecked by this old again democratic
policy not popular Joe Biden meanwhile
trying to try it out another creative
policy by which we mean an old policy
that accomplished nothing
he had an editorial in the Washington
Post yesterday in which in the New York
Times rather in which he argued in favor
of an assault weapons ban again doesn't
matter that it didn't work between 94
and 2004 Biden wrote many police
departments have reported an increase in
criminals using assault weapons since
2004 multiple analyses of the data
around mass shootings provide evidence
that from 1994 to 2004 the years when
assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines were banned there were fewer
mass shootings fewer deaths fewer
families families needlessly destroyed
but um that's not really true
Robert Verbruggen writing for the
National Review he points out that the
studies that Biden links to really one
study are very very flawed he says first
a quick bit of history the US had a ban
on assault weapons semi-automatic guns
with certain combinations of tactical
cosmetic features including pistol grips
and folding stocks from 1994 to 2004 the
existing guns were not confiscated it
was just illegal to sell new ones the
same law banned high-capacity magazines
setting the threshold attend rounds
which is actually below the standard
capacity of many modern handguns after
the ban was allowed to expire experts
were more or less unanimous that it
hadn't had a strong effect on overall
homicide certainly there are fewer of
the banned items in circulation but the
laws definition of assault weapon
focused on features that don't really
affect a guns lethality few murders are
committed with long guns of any kind to
say nothing of assault weapons in
particular recently though some have
claimed that the law reduced mass
shootings in particular which account
for a tiny fraction of overall homicides
but commands an incredibly
disproportionate amount of public
attention what seems to be true is that
the ban yers were relatively peaceful on
this front despite covering the rash of
school shootings that included Columbine
however the three most important facts
about mass shootings are one they have
historically been incredibly rare with
entire years passing without one
sometimes be
they aren't contagious with high profile
incidents inspiring copycats and
competitors and see they are incredibly
variable in the number of fatalities
from a low bound of wherever the
researcher chooses to set it the study
Biden cites uses for not including the
perpetrator all the way up to 58 and Las
Vegas trying to detect a pattern in data
like this then attributing the pattern
to a single law change that covered the
entire country for a 10-year period is
madness some charts from the studies
show the core problem here the total
counts of mass shooting fatalities by
year shows that these things go in
spurts and recent years in particular
have been horrible but that doesn't show
that the assault weapons ban mattered
and because the fact is that again what
it shows is that there was a these kind
of speights between 1998 and 2001 and
then there was a spate between 2010 that
is really radically increased so the
this sort of data does not support Joe
Biden's argument plus it's not going to
be popular you tell people that they
can't buy the rifle they want good luck
with that
so Democrats have been relegated to
going back to the drawing board and
they're drawing board is Donald Trump is
the cultural warrior as I have said
Donald Trump certainly is a cultural
warrior he was elected to be a cultural
warrior it's why his base loves the
tweets about Chris Cuomo loves them hey
I think that they're hilarious I think
very often those kinds of tweets damage
him and not the Cuomo one I don't think
the Cuomo one does anything to him but I
think that when he tweets out about
people going back to their home
countries and their Americans I think
that stuff damages him and frankly I
think it should damage him politically
because it's bad but he was elected to
be a cultural warrior that's a feature
not a bug that's why he was elected but
he was elected in response to a culture
war that the Wright already knew was
being waged by the left upon them the
left again is now trying to claim that
that Year Zero was Trump's election I'll
get to this in just in one second first
let's talk about the best mattress on
the market I'm talking about he looks
sleep mattresses these are so good that
I actually got one for my sister and her
husband when she got married my sister
said you know do you know of a really
good mattress I said well obviously I do
because I know everything but helix
sleep is the mattress you should get I
actually bought one for her for her
wedding they are phenomenal my wife and
I have a helix sleep mattress and makes
our sleep comfortable every night hulex
sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep
differences so the perfect mattress for
you no matter how you sleep on your side
on your back hot sleeper whatever helix
can make what your body needs we
particularly have a firm mattress that
really minimizes the heat very important
for me to sleep that way
helix makes it happen for me just go to
helix sleep calm /ban take their two
minutes leave quiz they will match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life for
couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and fuel
preferences for each side they've got a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 125
bucks off all mattress orders for our
listeners right now cap to 125 bucks off
at helix sleep comm slash Ben that's
helix sleep comm slash Ben for up to 125
dollars off that mattress order helix
sleep comm slash Ben okay so in just a
second we'll get to the lefts case that
Donald Trump is the leading cause of the
cultural Wars not true well gets that in
just one second first gang we are in the
homestretch they're just a handful of
days left to purchase tickets to our
backstage live show a special one-night
only event on August 21st at the
fantastic Terrace theater in Long Beach
California I'll be there daily we're a
god-king jeremy boring will be there
Andrew Clavin will be there and Michael
Knowles will be there like the stalker
you didn't know you had live will be
talking politics pop culture answering
your questions from the audience like
the good frado's we are tickets are
available at daily wire.com slash
backstage including our limited VIP
packages who are you a VIP are you a
special person you should be these VIP
packages guarantee premium seating
photos meet and greets with each of us a
gift from me I've been shopping for for
you I think you'll love it and more
they're selling fast head on over to
daily wire.com slash backstage we're
almost sold out by the end of the week
certainly will be sold out get yours
today
that's daily wire comm slash a backstage
go check it out right now also subscribe
over at daily wire comm you know the
pitch so just do it already ninety-nine
bucks a year gets you this your very
greatest in all beverage vessels that
left this year is how to record tumblr
go enjoy it right now you will love it
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say with the Democrats failing
on policy this leaves them with their
backup plan their backup plan is that
Donald Trump is the most divisive force
in the history of the country and that
Donald Trump must be stopped and to that
end the Democrats are ratcheting up
divisive rhetoric they're ratcheting up
the sort of rhetoric that actually does
increase the chances of violence and
does lead to greater opposition between
Americans of different political views
see when you call Trump a Nazi you're
calling his supporters Nazis when you
say that Trump is a white supremacist
you are suggesting that his supporters
are racists or at the very least
ambivalent or uncaring about racism
which is not true and yet this has
become the Democratic talking point -
sure
here is Kamala Harris who can't explain
to an old woman why she won't steal our
health insurance but also will say the
Donald Trump is responsible for the all
pass a Walmart shooting this stuff is
not new in our country it certainly
predates the election of Donald Trump
but it has also increased under Donald
Trump and you know he's he's been
fueling the flames of hate and you know
I've said recently you know on the issue
of El Paso you know know when people ask
me is he responsible for those killings
well no I mean he obviously didn't pull
the trigger
but he's sure been tweeting out the
ammunition oh wow he's tweeting out the
ammunition so that's what we're gonna do
now so when Barack Obama ripped in two
police officers routinely across the
country suggested they were racist and
then a evil member of black lives matter
decided to shoot up Dallas police
officers he didn't pull the trigger but
did he tweet out the ammunition did he
did again this is this is a a talking
point that actually is in and of itself
dangerous crediting your political
opponents with violence is a dangerous
thing to do and yet you are seeing folks
on the Left do it and and the language
of the left the not the entire left but
the radical left right certain members
of the left the language that is
accepted in high ranking circles in the
left is extraordinary extraordinary we
keep hearing about the right is so
accepting of Donald Trump's rhetoric I
think that the right has been too
accepting of a lot of things that Donald
Trump has said that's why I've tried to
be a fair-minded conservative in
condemning Trump when he says things
that I think are morally reprehensible
the left has had no such compunction
let's take an example so over the
weekend there's a guest on MSNBC named
Eli mystile who is a
above the law and he literally said that
Trump supporters who are white should be
destroyed
how'd is that gonna make the countries
that can make the country better is that
a culture war leveraged by Trump
supporters or is this a comment that
contributes to the flames just throwing
gasoline on the flames that already
exists communicated to them you beat
them you beat them they are not a
majority of this country the majority of
white people in this country are not a
majority of the country and and all the
people who are not fooled by this need
to come together go to the polls go to
the protests do whatever you have to do
you do not negotiate with these people
you destroy them you destroy them you
destroy Trump supporters you destroy
these people you don't negotiate with
these people you destroy them because
they're all racists no don't worry it's
only the right that is fighting a
culture war right here and this
predictably leads to the backlash and
there is a clip going around yesterday
of an Iowa voter who was asked who he's
voting for and he said basically they
keep calling me a racist and then he
described why he is not a racist and
this led the media to predictably enough
column racist here's the clip and I'll
explain why the media take away the
wrong lesson what do they call you
[Music]
I went to school I shared my Garn
well the colored guy I have nothing
against him I grew up in the East with
people do you think the producers are
racist though no I don't I really don't
okay so the evidence here is that
because he used the word colored which
is a very old-fashioned out-of-date word
for black people then he must be a
racist so he says you guys keep calling
me a racist so I'm gonna vote for Trump
and they're like well that's cuz you're
a racist keep going with this I'm sure
that do you want to win that guy's voter
no so according to you I missed all
probably that guy has to be destroyed
because he may have shared his dorm with
a black guy and he may not be a racist
and you don't know who that guy is you
don't know his record you have any
record of him being racist other than he
used an out-of-date word with regard to
black people and did it seem like when
he spit out the word colored that he was
doing it because he knew it was a racial
slur or it seemed like he's an old dude
who was using a dated term for black
people that was used back in the 1960s
and but the media immediately written
this is evident Trump voters are racist
right so the accusation is Trump voters
are racist
so Trump voters say you're gonna call me
a racist go to hell you know that guy
out there you keep calling a racist I'm
not gonna trust your take on him either
when it comes to the culture wars there
are two sides it is not a one-sided
culture war it is a two-sided culture
war and the media's attempts to derive a
narrative from this are absurd there's
an article in The Washington Post today
from Toulouse Oliver NEPA and Ashley
Parker called everything that we hold
dear from race to plastic straws Trump
dials up culture wars and divisive play
for twenty twenty votes oh really well
I'm old enough to remember in 2012 when
Barack Obama was suggesting the Mitt
Romney was a racist who hated women and
Joe Biden was out there suggesting that
Mitt Romney the most milquetoast human
ever to walk the earth one is about
black people back in Chains but listen
to the way the Washington Post handles
is again it's the Washington Post's
unwillingness to recognize that the left
is a side in the culture war they're not
even a side see if you're on the left
you can't even acknowledge that you're a
side and there's this weird phenomenon
where you don't think you have an accent
and there are lots of accents around
America I don't think I have an accent
right I think that I sound like how
people normally speak English if I speak
to somebody from New York they can't
hear very often they have a New York
accent somebody from the South believes
they have no act
I have an accent British people speaking
English don't understand they've a
British accent when you're in the accent
you don't understand that you're
speaking with an accent typically
speaking it's only when you start trying
to speak with somebody else's accent
that you realize that maybe you have an
accent of your own well the same thing
is true in politics right now people
fail to recognize that they have a
political bent and so if you're on the
left and Donald Trump is saying stuff
you think I'm just a fair-minded
individual who has not taken part in the
culture wars it's just that horrible
Trump and this is what you get from the
journalists at the Washington Post so
much journalism I would say that this
article is fake news except I know from
Chris Cuomo that's the equivalent of the
n-word or something any case this
article says george w bush had freedom
fries sarah palin had the big gulp dan
quayle had the hollywood portrayal of an
unwed single mother named Murphy Brown
for president trumpets paper straws the
latest addition to an ever-growing list
of cultural flashpoints his campaign is
seeking to highlight as part of a base
focused reelection effort remember that
time that Barack Obama flashed a rainbow
flag on the White House after albers
fell remember that was that like a
culture pointer now was that a cultural
flashpoint or how about that time he
said that the Cambridge police acted
stupidly was that a cultural flashpoint
or no or when his campaign made a big
deal out of MIT Romney suggesting that
he had binders of female candidates
brought before him for hiring was that a
cultural flashpoint or or not a cultural
flash point when Barack Obama said the
Trayvon Martin could have been as a
cultural flashpoint or no but they only
exist on the right because George W Bush
said freedom fries once I mean man oh
man as cities and coffee chains across
the country have adopted policies aimed
at limiting environmental damage the
president's campaign has targeted what
he calls liberal paper straws it's
selling a Trump branded plastic version
as a fundraising tool so I love that it
is not considered political to ban
straws and restaurants it is considered
political to oppose a ban on straws at
restaurants by the way
papers frost suck radically they're
awful they collapse in on themselves and
they taste like garbage they're terrible
if you if you want to talk about banning
the plastic cups at Starbucks okay I
promise you those cups have more plastic
in them than the straws do there the ban
on straws takes people off because it
feels like virtue signaling that has no
real impact on the environment and Trump
is not wrong to pick on that because
that's kind of what it is for a lot of
folks
pointing to the runaway success of the
straws which have earned the campaign
more than 670 grand a month
communications director Tim Murtagh said
they represent Trump's ability to make a
political point using a cultural issue
every day voters can relate to and it's
true Trump is good at this but again
Trump isn't the only one who is good at
this the washington post though says
trump is deliberately amplifying public
tensions by seizing on divisive topics
to energize his base according to
campaign aides and White House advisors
I thought this was just called policy
called politics but listen to this tank
I mean you on a hot take from the
Washington Post here it is
as Democrats debate policy Trump has
sought to force his potential rivals to
defend the most far-reaching cultural
ideas circulating within their party oh
is it debating policy when a OSE
released a frequently asked questions
calling for a ban on cows and air travel
was that debating policy or is that a is
it really debating policy when Kamala
Harris suggests the Trump is responsible
for a mass shooting in El Paso or is
that more like her just actually looking
for a cultural flashpoint the blindness
of the media to their own bias is one of
the reasons why people don't trust the
media and why people think that Chris
Cuomo is afraid oh this is why it's why
people people let's be real about this
people on the right think the entire
media is Fredo
they think the entire media is a bunch
of weaklings masquerading as smart
people who believe they are brilliant
brighter than you but in fact are taking
waitresses two at a time and bankrupting
casinos and that's that's what most
Americans think of the media at this
point okay meanwhile we got to run
through some other news here so it turns
out that Jeffrey Epstein hanged himself
at the prison bed sheet how the do two
ended up with a bedsheet
after being on suicide watch is insane
apparently his lawyers wanted him off
suicide watch which makes it sound
premeditated the suicide and you take
the guy off suicide his lawyers ago he
said you know he's not gonna commit
suicide I'll be fine I'll be fine just
take the other guy out of the cell take
him off suicide watch he's gone
I mean shocker according to the New York
Post Epstein was found hanging in his
lower Manhattan jail cell with a
bedsheet wrapped around his neck secured
to the top of a bunk bed
how'd he end up in a bunk bed because he
was in a cell by himself because they
removed the person who was in the cell
with him all of which is going to make
people somewhat suspicious he apparently
killed himself by kneeling toward the
floor and then strangling himself with
the makeshift news which is a pretty
terrible way to go
staffers attempted to revive him he was
taken to an infirmary inside the lockup
and then he was pronounced dead so with
him presumably will die some of his
secrets there was an article I believes
in the New York Times yesterday from a
columnist who said he met with Epstein
off the record and then now has printed
a story about how Epstein knew all these
famous people and had dirt on them you
know off the record I understand you
want to keep your journalistic ethics
but when you're talking to a convicted
pedophile I feel like most people can be
okay with you spilling on who he may
have mentioned they're a bunch of
security lapses at the jail according to
the Daily Mail the 66 year old was found
alone and unresponsive in his cell his
defense attorney has since faulted jail
officials apparently last year a prison
guard at the jail pled guilty to taking
more than 25 grand in cash bribes to
smuggle cell phones alcohol and food to
a wealthy Turkish gold trader between
2016 and 2017 he also received thousands
of dollars in payments from another
inmate which were given to him by the
prisoners relatives and a paralegal
representing him he was sentenced in
January to three years in prison by a
judge who called the crime an assault on
our entire system of justice so this guy
was not the person who was guarding
Epstein suffice it to say the corruption
in prisons is indeed a thing so there
are open questions about exactly what
went wrong here also Jeffery Epstein's
little black book is now in the
possession of federal authorities he
apparently listed 301 British associates
over a thousand associates generally now
just because you're in somebody's phone
doesn't mean that you were benefiting
from their sex trafficking but this dude
did travel in powerful circles the FBI
apparently raided so-called pedophile
Island yesterday so we'll find out what
exactly they found on pedophile Island
in other news I wanna give you the
update on the situation in Hong Kong
which continues to get more and more
tense why President Trump has not spoken
out about this but about Chris Cuomo is
beyond me and the President of the
United States ought to ignore the Fredo
stuff and focus in on you know the
millions of protesters in the streets
who may be about to be mowed down by the
Chinese government wouldn't this be a
time as I said yesterday on my radio
show would this not be a time for the
President of the United States to
ratchet up the pressure on China he's in
the middle of a trade war with them
wouldn't this be a great
time to explain to the American people
that the reason that we have to take
harsh measures against China is because
they are insanely aggressive with people
they've already made agreements with
including the people of Hong Kong not to
violate their sovereignty and now
they're about to run tanks in there
apparently the the trucks and the tanks
are massing at the border the Hong Kong
protesters completely at the mercy of
the Chinese government at this point
according to the Washington Post
anti-government protesters brought chaos
to Hong Kong's Airport for a second
consecutive day on Tuesday they forced
Airlines to suspend check-in for
departing flights as demonstrators
extended their standoff with authorities
who have been unable to quote months of
dissent after mass cancellations the
previous evening flights had been
gradually returning to normal throughout
Tuesday even as thousands of black clad
demonstrators returned to occupy the
terminal with placards denouncing police
brutality and calling for freedom for
Hong Kong by the way they were waving
the American flag for all of those
people in America who think that
America's flag is not a symbol of
freedom around the world look at the
flag that the folks in Hong Kong were
waving then waving the Turkish flag then
we're waving the French flag they're
waving the American flag and that is for
a reason America still symbolizes
freedom around the world it's why it
behooves the president Donald Trump
needs to speak out now about what China
needs to do with these protesters and
that is leave them alone and deal with
them as the sovereign people they are
hey China is a tyranny it is a communist
tyranny we've all blinded ourselves to
that fact because they produce China
because they produce cheap goods for us
but that has nothing to do with the
amount of tyranny they steep on their
own people in fact there's a case to be
made that opening China back in the
1970s well necessary in order to
counterbalance the Soviet Union we were
trying to split Mao from the from the
Stalinist over in Russia well may have
been a temporary expedient it is
radically strengthened a Chinese
communist regime that seeks to quash its
own people
if Trump wants the American people to
undertake economic sacrifice in the name
of fighting Chinese influence wouldn't
this be a great time to speak out when
Barack Obama did nothing as Iranian
protesters were mowed down in the
streets in 2009 those of us on the right
were extraordinarily critical as we
should have been Donald Trump needs to
speak out he needs to speak out now
about these Hong Kong protesters he
needs to make any resources available to
them available to them short
of heavy weaponry and light weaponry we
shouldn't providing what we don't want a
war obviously but we can exert an awful
lot of pressure on the Chinese
government to come to some sort of
arrangement with the people of Hong Kong
because gradually over the last 15 years
the Chinese government has been
violating its agreements with with Hong
Kong that was agreed to when the British
abandon Hong Kong to its fate at the
behest of the Chinese government okay
time for a quick thing I like and then a
quick thing that I hate so thing that I
like today yesterday on the program we
hosted Mohamed el-erian he's an
economist he's the former head of
Allianz and he is also the author of the
book the only game in town central
bank's instability and avoiding the next
collapse it's an easy-to-read book about
economics and about why it is that so
many people seem to be reliant on
central bank's his main thesis is that
the American economy the European
economy the Chinese economy all of these
economies have become more and more
reliant on policymaking from
institutions that were never meant to
make policy the Fed was never meant to
control American economic policy now the
markets respond directly to what the Fed
is doing after the 2008-2009 financial
crisis the Fed exerted more and more
influence and power the same thing
happened in Europe
it was supposed to be a temporary
expedient instead it has become the new
normal and that's dangerous because you
can't just inflate and deflate
currencies raise and lower interest
rates and hope to fix economies that way
there are underlying structural problems
with economies that have to be dealt
with including the fact by the way that
the United States continues to run up
these record deficits federal spending
has set a record through July 3.7
trillion dollars have been spent in the
first ten months of fiscal year 2019 the
government is now running a yearly
deficit of 867 billion dollars that's
insane these are numbers that are
unthinkably large and they are going to
undermine the future of a productive
American economy you can't rely on the
Fed to bail you out of that thing simply
through inflation the US budget deficit
already exceeds last year's total figure
and again we are only ten months into
the fiscal year so this is all bad news
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
if you're in the state of California
take your kids out of public school the
public schools are garbage and not only
are they garbage they are run by people
who are interested in cramming down a
left word view of the world upon your
children the latest evidence of this
according to Adam credo at the
Washington free beacon the state of
California has now introduced blatantly
anti-semitic and anti-israel lessons
into its official high school curriculum
drawing outrage and concern in the state
see Jewish and pro-israel communities
according to multiple sources involved
in the controversy the California
Department of Education is facing
backlash after permitting a host of
anti-israel activists to build a
statewide educational curriculum that
demonizes Israel and is said to be
fostering hatred of Jewish and Israeli
American students apparently they're a
bunch of anti-semitic courses that are
fostering an unsafe environment for
Jewish and Israeli American students
according to the Washington free beacon
a coalition of 83 pro-israel
organizations led by the AMA initiative
which is a watchdog group says we are
aware that many individuals and groups
affiliated with the Jewish community
have already written to you about the
education council's shocking omission of
information about American Jews and
anti-semitism its use of classic
anti-semitic stereotypes it's blatant
anti-israel bias the proposed curriculum
is ridiculous it portrays Jews in Israel
as quote part of interlocking systems of
oppression and privilege they endorse
the California education system
explicitly endorsing the anti-semitic
boycott divestment and sanctions
movement that specifically seeks to
destroy the State of Israel as designed
by its advocates to do just that
the curriculum itself is ridiculous on
nearly every level it is not just about
anti-semitism but the but there are
insane violations of normalcy and
educational realism in this program
there here are some of the terms that
are used in this ethnic studies model
curriculum now being perpetuated by the
California Department of Education they
talk about her Kasturi K H X R sto ry b
this is radical nonsense these cysts
hetero patriarchy grievin that you're
supposed to be taught grievances about
capitalism colonialism and imperialism
before eyes of oppression
ideological institutional interpersonal
and internalized internalized depression
means that you disagree with the
prevailing leftist orthodoxy
you're supposed to be taught about
patriarchy sexism heterogeneity
patriarchy white supremacy xenophobia as
you know xenophobia rather and the
ethnic studies course overview only
singles out marginalization or
discrimination against five groups
hey who Latinas blacks Asians Native
Americans and Arab Americans Jews
notoriously left out though they are the
number-one targets of auntie's of hate
crimes in the United States the
particular section of the course
overview talking about the oppression of
Arab Americans specifically identifies
the country of Israel as quote Israel
Palestine Palestine does not exist it
discusses the quote unquote Nakba which
is the supposed dispossession and
dispersal of Palestinians from the new
State of Israel in the 1948 war the
lesson plan includes hip-hop as
resistance and contrast busta rhymes of
song arab money with Narsee song the
real arab money' and then calls for
boycott divestment and sanctions there's
still time to protest this the
department is accepting public comment
through this thursday august 15th but
this is all absurdity of course the the
absurdity of the california educational
system has been known for a long time
kids can't read or do math but we must
teach them about the sis hetero
patriarchy and herc stirry solid stuff
solid stuff already we'll be back here
later today two additional hours of
content plus we'll be back here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Caro Mina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant NIC
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
20:19 if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
[Music]